[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir cornichons
gros soir pepita bonsoir petite araignée
au nom l'ont pas d'araignée ce soir moi
je n'ai pas beaucoup d'amitié pour ces
bestioles je les trouve bien trop
bizarre bizarre
pourquoi nous nous revoyons patron est
ce que je m'amuse mois à cracher du fil
et à fabriquer des toiles non mais tu
n'es pas une araignée c'est vrai je suis
un nounours et je descends tout
simplement avec mon échelle et non pas
avec un fil d'araignée
mon et shan
comme ça hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop
[Musique]
ce sont des toiles d'araignées elle
sauvait n'est ce pas de nous
[Musique]
moors attention mais ce toit entre mes
doigts très fort pour ne pas abîmer les
toiles d'araignées je ne suis pas si je
m'arrête ce soir entré chez ram y entrer
puisque vous insistez
ou
hulu
petite araignée mignonne ces nounours il
est gentil vous voyez il n'a pas bien
mais les filles que vous avez tissé
cette nuit ou au hula on secours je vais
avoir une bosse je me suis connue
l'acteur tenait là il faut mettre de
l'eau froid il faut mettre de l'eau
chant et vous mettre du vinaigre
qu'est ce qui lie anja haut mettez vous
d'accord
toi
là ça va mieux non non ça me brûle au
sérieux attends attends ça c'est
meilleur tiens là non non ça pique au
jeu ont-ils survécu mais je sais ce qui
va guérir notre nounours quoi un petit
bérigny banon je t'en prie pepita je
n'ai pas envie de rire qui a mal ne peut
rire mais elle vaut mieux rire que
pleurer
[Musique]
voilà un baiser dernier c'est ça
alors j'aime les baisers dans red bull
puisque ce sont des baisers de pepita et
je me sens mieux tu n'es plus fâché avec
les arrêts mienne non non mais je trouve
qu'elle serait mieux dehors de ton qu'à
l'intérieur de la roulotte un gameplay
dès qu'elles seront bien réchauffé s en
iront regarder ce qu'elle son ravisseur
c'est possible mais je préfère les voir
de loin que de près ces ravissantes tu
vas y lit à la maman et la petite ils
veulent voir si la baisse dès maintenant
ça va mieux ça va mieux ça va même
paiement mieux que je m'en vais
bah qu'est ce que tu as pu toi tu a
régné sur la truffe bon j'vais pas ça
veut dire bonne nuit les araignées et
tardons pas de nuit les enfants
[Musique]
je m'appelle
où bodo et toi majali mais je t'emmène
epita retiens tu dans ta main et marine
guitare il n'arrivait
à demain peu plus tard ou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au secours au secours pas trop mais que
se passe-t-il ce n'est plus une roulotte
c'est une véritable toile d'araignée
il ne nous reste plus qu'à fuir mais
calme toi nounours la lune va changer et
les araignées vont tranquillement
retourner dans leurs forêts c'est ce que
dame dit pas trop elles sont très
mignonne ces petites araignées quand
elles tissent leur toile
dans la forêt de valle rassurer bientôt
tu seras ami avec les arts emmy bornes
on ne compte pas au revoir les enfants
allez vite vous coucher et feu de boer
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]